this kind of question of should ring
some bells because we had a look at them
under complex numbers and that's because
the guts of this question
Rivera should say to customers question
the the spark feed especially is to
waters through right that's where it
begins which is going to be something
which we dealt with you know if there's
topic however when you have a look at
these later parts of it do you really
have to draw back on like what we are
currently looking at even polynomials
you should really refer to the
fundamental theorem are when you're
going through this at least in your head
so I'm going to deal with these
questions down maybe they're not
familiar with you for you or this is
just so long ago you like don't know
let's just keep the demographic okay so
you can see the three plots I've kind of
written it it slightly beautiful used
embarrassing to express cos 3 theta as a
function of course they don't just like
yesterday we were looking at polynomial
of the identities and I said Express
this for T as a function of a quadratic
in this V right so this is exactly the
same deal we need to remember what
tomorrow's theorem is right so let's
have a go at it okay I'm going to begin
by saying cos 3 theta now cos 2 theta in
terms of tomorrow sin which is about
coffee sellers is only 1/2 of a number
right what's the other half
it's gonna be it's gonna be the
imaginary part right this is the real
part so I need the imaginary part which
should have the same argument yes so
that's why when I read that top question
de Barras includes me to the fact that
even it isn't a complex complicated I
have to invoke a clock like someone to
use tomorrow's do does that make sense
okay so what does do Marvis theorem
actually space what's that equal to
let me give you my card
here are some brackets and there's gonna
be some cosines and it's going to be
some signs implicit pause
isn't it so good and we have a really a
question like this let me help you you
just have a complex up right and the
whole point of tomorrow serve is if you
take a complex number and you raise it
to some power okay
all that means is you take its modulus
which in this case is 1 you raise it to
the same house
then you take its argument and that's
where the really interesting thing
happens and you multiply it where you
add it the number of times of one of
your parents because that's what happens
when you multiply complex numbers you
add the argument successive times now
you can see if I've got a three-peat
over here that means I have multiplied
this complex number three times there
you go mother
okay I'm gonna understate them
okay now you can see that's where I
begin
oh is this juice what am I know what I
have to do with this like that's just a
fan okay I'm going to have to expand
we're gonna have to call on my knowledge
of binding you're gonna say this thing
should be because it's cute I think I
got Pascal triangle it's one two three
three one okay and then I have these
guys in increasing and decreasing water
so the first one I've got one of these
that's the first term cute then I'm
going to get three of there's the first
term squared and I'm going to get one of
this guy
yes like so and I've got 100 there's the
next three
I'm only gonna have one of the real part
I'm gonna have two of the imaginary part
and then I'm gonna finish off thank you
okay happy remembering it for about a
minute okay
all right you can see where I'm going
right the whole point here is that I
actually only really am interested in
the real part okay so the whole point of
expanding is so I can tease out the real
part and then I can ignore the rest of
it okay so you can see here because I
actually know where I'm going which of
the terms that are going to be
interesting
which ones okay the first one is
obviously real and this one is also
going to be real because the eyes are
going to become they leave one in that
that's right so in fact I'm gonna be a
little bit cheap I'm gonna take those
guys out the front right a little chunk
in me brackets and I picture myself on
grouping these and here that I swear it
will become minus 3 cos theta
sighing Peter are you okay with that
just for the sake of completeness I
should finish off the rest of it in a
normal question you might not
necessarily know oh I only interested in
the real part I'm only interested in the
event very much
so I'm just going to do the rest of it
for the secular you can see this part
here that's that's pretty standard I'm
going to take that factor of I had to
indicate car this is imaginary now I'm
gonna have three chi-squared so what do
I end up with this guy okay yeah so I've
taken one of the eyes out leaving two
behind and they become a minus sign so
this is going to be minus sign so what
are the questions you actually be asking
us something about say sign free thing
up obviously this would be the part okay
so far so good so over here I'm just
going to rewrite this because I'm about
to do my comparison of real and
imaginary parts I'm only interested in
the real flat so I'm going to say
equating real parts I'm going to just
point out right corners three theta
that's real equals
okay now this is good it's true but I
haven't answered the question
what I need to do this - yeah good I
don't have this function cos theta I had
costea's but I also have science mixed
in there so I'm gonna get rid of that
it's a sine squared - all I have to do
is what - god it's pretty good
I'm just gonna be able to squeeze it in
here with you okay you can see here that
if you combine this cos theta and the
sorry this is 3 cos theta and this cos
squared theta you're going to get 3 cos
cute there's already clothes queued up
the front so I'm going to get four of
these guys here and then this guy
there's nothing else to collect it so it
just ends up with that